you have to ask them what their thinking
is and why that
they would continue to do this carol
baskin has something to say about the
defamation lawsuit filed by the family
of her missing second husband
don lewis news of the lawsuit broke
shortly before the tiger king star hit
the ballroom floor on tuesday for
dancing with the stars live
show following her performance the big
cat rescue ceo
gave e.t her two cents on the suit
i haven't made any kind of jokes about
don's disappearance that has been a very
personal thing to me for years
and on cameo people reach out to me all
the time and they want me to say things
about that and i just decline their
requests because i'm not going to make
fun of something that was so painful for
all of us according to court documents
obtained by
e.t don's daughters gail linda and donna
as well as his former executive
assistant anne mcqueen
claim that carol was complicit with
jokes about her former husband's death
on dancing with the stars
when judges brought up tick-tock videos
inspired by her storyline in tiger king
carol baskin you danced that pasto you
smashed it
in their lawsuit the family claims that
carol didn't condem
or correct the comments about don the
family also accuses her of being
complicit with jokes about dawn in her
good morning america interview
earlier this month when she allegedly
promised to quote
really kill it next week carol said she
learned of the suit
right before her performance and she
even kept the news a secret from her
dance partner pasha
you have to ask them what their thinking
is and why that
they would continue to do this didn't
stop me from doing
my best as i did last week of course by
last week
she's referencing the commercial that
aired during the premiere
episode of the hit dancing competition
we need to know what happened to our
father
the spot featured don's family and their
attorney
john phillips don lewis mysteriously
disappeared in 1997.
his family deserves answers they deserve
justice
do you know who did this or if carol
baskin was involved
100 000 reward has been funded you can
call the tip line
at the time carol told e.t the whole
thing didn't surprise her
it's just been i think a huge publicity
stunt on their part so what more could
they possibly do than that
et also spoke to the family's attorney
they wanted their message out there they
wanted at least locally
to counter-message carol baskins
in their mind lies and fraud and he
explained why the family took out the ad
what better way to to take advantage of
an opportunity
than be there where she is to to take a
moment
in between the breaks of dancing with
the stars and say look
dancing with the stars isn't going to
play the family's messaging they're not
going to give them a forum
so let's take a form let's let's take a
moment
to say hey wait a minute there's this
there's this
mystery of don lewis that still hasn't
been solved
let's stop and realize that there is an
actual death uh
involved here and and be serious and
maybe somebody will come forward
if not at least people today will be
talking about don lewis
and not just carol baskin as for carol
she got emotional during this week's
episode
i've seen what the media can do to you
and i hate that
i try even harder to be strong in their
presence i keep it inside and
wait until everybody's gone before i can
break down
and i don't know how to make it better
and she admitted to e.t
that she wishes she hadn't cried i tried
for a very long time not to cry while we
were talking about some of the things
that were so
personal as far as the negative impact
of tiger king on my family
and so it was just by virtue of the fact
that i was completely worn down
and broke down and i i regret
crying on tv or in front of my family
and of course you know that just worried
them even that much more
when they saw it they were like oh my
gosh she's breaking down under the
pressure there we've got to get her out
and i'm like no i'm fine